my name is Oliver Oh Bertie my design
editor for National Geographic magazine
the EPA had conducted some studies at
sites around the country wondering if
all the pharmaceuticals that we've been
prescribed we've taken our ending up in
our watersheds and ending up in the
wildlife when we certain looking at the
results of the amount of medications
that are showing up in these fish we
thought we do with that and I said well
it's easy we'll just make a fish out of
pills all the green and yellow ones are
the antidepressants Prozac and the tiny
white ones that make up the dorsal fins
are a generic version then we've got an
antihypertensive medication for the air
bubbles the bright magenta pills and the
blue pills are both antihistamines and
the pink pills are an anti-seizure
medication the eye of the fish is also
anti-seizure medication but in a higher
dosage
the joy of working on pieces like this
at National Geographic is that you get
to communicate a message is very serious
and very important but you can do it in
a playful way that invites people in and
gets them to look twice